[Music]
this is it your bachelorette weekend
what's on my head there's gonna be so
many hot Miami babes we are gonna be
swimming and dick girls hi Alice Peter
hi and get out of here she's mine now
yeah I'm getting too much trouble up
there yeah I want the Wallace
fifth-floor girls are back together we
don't get to see each other a lot
because we're all so busy with our lives
- what'd he do for work these days
well sing a song Roger is the drain a
potty clown is the reality but this
weekend's all about us just like old
times
Chris I just got coke from the Busboys
why so everyone's a dumb dumb animal
stop being a stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
little [ __ ] cocaine sorry I did a
little bit
[Music]
don't
[Music]
first amazing a minute
[Music]
Guddu beans let's get to the meat Micah
feel special I'll look it up on YouTube
he's dead oh god I can't the guy time to
call the police no no no no flipped over
aah and then we'll call the police let's
get rid of all the drugs I wanna tell by
doing them okay so one tell me what to
do and I will do it
uh-huh my uncle's a lawyer should call
him first sounds like this was an
accident
thank God you don't touch the body what
okay so actually we have already moved
he me that could be up to 15 years in
prison
oh my god yes is everything all right
this could still be the best weekend our
parking lot
just smile limit right smile more
[Music]
hi baby boy sleep now
oh god no no no no
[Music]
you
you